merci madame la présidente et à la suite
des propos du rapporteur grémillet je
vais essayer
de rendre la position la plus claire
possible
vous reconnaîtrez en écho un certain
nombre de vos propos notamment sur le
caractère pas assez dissuasif de l'état
du droit à cette heure concernant
ces arnaques en bande organisée j'avais
à coeur
d'étayer le point de vue du gouvernement
effectivement monsieur le rapporteur
je vais passer vite vous êtes tous
conscient je crois du fait qu'avec
l'émergence du web et et de tous les
supports électroniques
en réalité on a une mutation profonde
des pratiques commerciales trompeuses
on a tout un niveau de un nouveau type
d' arnaque entre guillemets qui émerge
des arnaques qui sont à la fois plus
sophistiqués vous êtes nombreux à le
savoir mais elles sont aussi de plus en
plus que mise à très grande échelle et
enfin de plus en plus en bande organisée
avec de nombreux intermédiaires souvent
dans des réseaux très bien organisés et
dans de nombreux pays
face à cette réalité
j'ai souhaité partager quelques chiffres
pardonner lalala lis un peu à la prévert
mais ça me semble de bon aloi sur cet
article 9 quelques chiffres sont les
placements financiers
60 ch qu'on n'a pas dans ses leçons
signalements à la dgccrf en 2021 avec
une nette augmentation
concernant les allégations mensongères
de haut rendement les crypto actifs les
investissements sur des biens divers les
vins les cheptels les forêts les fausses
cagnotte
les dons ne sont pas en reste les
regroupements de crédits avec crédits
supplémentaires mais aussi concernant
les placements financiers vous donner ce
chiffre avec un préjudice moyen
préjudice financier moyen de 72 mille
euros par victime
pour les escroqueries au livret
d'epargne 12000 euros pour celle au
crédit est d'à peu près 20 mille euros
pour les crypto actifs de 70000 euros en
moyenne
pour les chambres d pad je pense que ces
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes je veux
partager avec vous si vous m'autorisez
madame la présidente quelques éléments
sur la rénovation énergétique qui n'est
pas en reste en matière aussi de
développement de ces pratiques
frauduleuses en 2021 cinquante deux pour
cent des 6 128 entreprises contrôlées en
infraction
c'est à dire plus de la majorité d'entre
elles soit défaut d'information du
consommateur soit violation du droit de
rétractation soit violation des règles
du crédit soit les trois en même temps
118 injonction 94 procès verbaux péno
pour les cas les plus graves 4000
signalements enregistrés au premier
semestre 2022 sur signal conso j'en
profite pour saluer l'énorme engagement
de la dgccrf est je crois la
l'importance de ce site signale conso
pour tous les consommateurs de france
4000 signalements enregistrés au premier
sms de 1022 via cette plateforme en lien
avec les travaux et la rénovation
thermique or dépannage à domicile
pour vous dire chers sénateurs s'étaient
1682 signalement au premier semestre
2011 21 c'est à dire que nous en avons
plus du double en lin non
concernant enfin évidemment le compte
personnel de formation
32400 signalements reçus par la caisse
des dépôts premier semestre
2022 on à l'usurpation d'identité on a
d'inscription à des formations n'ont
souhaité à l'insu du consommateur le
préjudice estimé dans le cadre des
plaintes pénales déposées par la caisse
entre mars 2020 et mais 2022 s'élève à
27 millions d'euros les signalements cpf
au dispositif du 33700 sms indésirables
ont été multipliés et je conclurai par
la part 14
entre le premier semestre 2021 et le
premier semestre 2000 2
ces chiffres témoignent s'il le fallait
de la nécessité de légiférer pour
renforcer cet ordre public économique
ces arnaques je viens de vous donner des
chiffres elles sont présentes elles sont
croissantes et de plus en plus
sophistiqués nous proposons donc dans
cet article 9 d'adapter les moyens de
l'état et notamment ceux de la dgccrf
sur l'ensemble de la chaîne de contrôle
j'en termine oui nous voulons agir de
l'enquète aux sanctions en renforçant
les moyens d' enquête de la dgccrf
grâce à cet article 9 les agents de la
dgccrf pourront échanger des
informations avec la police judiciaire
pour faciliter l'élucidation des
enquêtes nous souhaitons aussi faciliter
la mise en oeuvre des mesures
correctives qui existe déjà pour
faciliter l'arrêt de certaines pratiques
vous avez en tête je crois le
déréférencement qui a été fait il ya
quelques semaines très récemment qui
vendait des produits à risques l'an
dernier se dérobe des référencements
pardon sera facilité dès lors que les
cas de fraude ont été avérés c'est
monsieur si ces mesures correctives ne
suffisent pas des sanctions sont
effectivement nécessaire pour mettre mal
mettre à mal ses arnaques croissante et
c'est pourquoi comme l'a dit le
rapporteur fort aussi de des conclusions
de la dgccrf et je veux le dire c'est
une administration dont j'ai l'honneur
d'avoir la charge et je peux vous dire
que s'ils nous disent que deux ans si
deux ans n'est pas dissuasive je crois
qu'ils ont l'expérience l' expertise au
quotidien pour les justifier le
rapporteur l'a dit c'est pourquoi nous
proposons de porter à trois ans la peine
de prison encourue en cas de commission
une pratique commerciale déloyale
donnant lieu à la signature d'un contrat
à 7 ans lorsque cette pratique et menez
vous l'avez compris en bande organisée
et enfin nous renforcerons la publicité
ou le naming des procédures publicité
qui est particulièrement utile
nous proposons enfin que les principales
procédures utilisées par la dgccrf
puisse faire l'objet d'une publicité que
ce soit en matière commerciale ou
concurrentielles
cette publicité j'en termine serait bien
sûr réservée aux cas de fraude les grave
je ne serai pas plus longue mais j'avais
à coeur de vous garantir la réalité de
la croissance exponentielle de ces
arnaques de ces pratiques frauduleuses
en ligne de leur sophistication et de la
nécessité d'adapter notre arsenal
juridique pour mieux protéger nos
consommateurs je vous remercie madame la
ministre vous avez ordonné moi j'oublie
donc l'essentiel j'aurais par conséquent
à un avis similaire à celui du
rapporteur défavorable sur
ou
défavorable un avis de sagesse alors moi
je donne un avis défavorable je suis
moins ça lui carrément d'accord sur les
quatre amendements chelsea désolé du
bafouillages merci madame la ministre
[Musique]